okay this is better i'm just in my car
i just dropped four new lip blush shades
this is for the girls that love
the look of a matte lip i just think
it's like
interesting because it's like you're a
billionaire girl like why are you
reviewing lip kits in your car when you
live in a multi-million dollar home
kylie jenner's clapping back at a
tick-tock user who called out the way
she films her videos and accused her of
being inauthentic you're always going to
have haters and negative comments
so we try not to read them oh but she
saw this one it all started when the
beauty mogul shared a video in her car
reviewing her latest lip kit today i'm
wearing sister sister which is an old
shade that we brought back
from the first kendall collection
the vid caught the attention of plastic
chandler a creator who often shares his
opinions on pop culture this time he
didn't call out what kylie said instead
it was how she filmed it why are you
reviewing lip kits in your car when you
live in a multi-million dollar home like
you did not just go to the store and
pick that up you didn't get home from
somewhere and get it from your mailbox
like
that was very deliberate of you going to
your car to do that and like the phone
drop was kind of cringy
these people have never lived a normal
life like ever and that's no hate to
them like they've it's like not their
thing
but they have to find these people that
have gotten popularity from being
somewhat normal and then they take their
personality and like their traits and
like what they do
so then they can make videos like that
and seem
normal enough so they can relate to us
because they are billionaires like this
is not something that kylie jenner does
on the normal i promise she does not
just sit in her car i don't think she
even drives them but
whatever
well chandler's video fell into kylie's
algorithm and she called him out in the
comments quote it's really not that deep
or calculated this video took me five
minutes to make and yes i still drive
and do normal things i love it
but this isn't the first time kylie's
jumped into the conversation to defend
herself in july a food delivery driver
made a video claiming he heard a baby
screaming in her home and called her a
bad tipper it's literally a 12 order for
pepperoni could have paid me more i
didn't see kylie i didn't see stormy but
i swear i heard a baby scream
in now deleted messages kylie commented
no one comes through the gate and added
the lying for attention rubs me the
wrong way
growing up in the spotlight kylie knows
a thing or two about dealing with
negative comments it's something she and
sister kendall opened up to et about
when they were still teenagers it's
extremely difficult and you're growing
and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but there's so many
blessings that come along with it too so
we're grateful for it not much to
complain about i think
having so many people
like love you is such a blessing i don't
know like you wouldn't expect this many
people to like care about you and want
to see you succeed so i think that
that's really awesome and we definitely
really appreciate it
[Music]